ce que tu dirais
Bruno petit j'ai adoré votre nouvelle
biographie parce que vous êtes une
personne très discrète mais là vous vous
confiez comme jamais auparavant et dans
le livre vous parlez de vos débuts de
cette période glamora sexe drogue rock
n' roll vous parlez d'acide de cocaïne
ouais mais attendez
j'étais pas on va dire on va dire comme
c'est j'étais pas sa peau de toutes les
soirs je t'ai pas quand même chanter de
toute façon en faisant en faisant de la
drogue j'ai fait cette vie là dans les
années 80 d'un gars dans 20 ans qui
essaie des choses mais rapidement je me
suis rendu compte et ça c'est à cause du
sport et des arts martiaux que la
discipline que j'ai dans ces dans ces
disciplines là fallait que je l'applique
à mon métier rapidement si je voulais
vraiment faire ça comme métier donc j'ai
complètement arrêté tout ça un moment
donné puis il y a eu comme une épiphanie
qui s'est passé sur un soir à cette île
et
il est 4h du matin je me vois dans le
miroir rapport après une nuit de
bamboche avec toute la gagne et puis
j'ai fait comme ok non ça marche pas là
on peut pas aller là j'y arriverai
jamais
après les bars votre carrière a changé
du tout au taux au début des années 90
après une rencontre avec Luc Plamondon
parce qu'il vous embauchez pour la
légende de Jimmy Starmania quel souvenir
regardez vous de cette période là pour
la discute Charlesbourg qui rêvait juste
de jouer du drame sur la scène de la
Polyvalente se ramassant à Paris tout
d'un coup c'était
et à Paris en famille avec Isabelle la
mère de mon fils mon fils qui était
encore aux couches le chien
ça a été toute une ride et on est parti
à Paris en 93 puis je vais m'en souvenir
toute ma vie c'est dans les plus belles
années de ma vie je pense parce qu'il y
avait encore une naissance innocence une
naïveté une innocence tu plonges dans
l'inconnu puis tu y vas comme tous les
projets que je fais hors ligne
[Musique]
écrire
vous avez été le premier Gringoire dans
notre âme de Paris c'était le succès
incroyable planétaire comment avez-vous
réussi à ne pas vous perdre la dent
parce que là c'est l'argent c'est
travailler tout le temps c'est fou là
[Musique]
je me suis perdu un peu tu as d'un côté
tout ce que tu aurais envie d'avoir tu
fais des tourner des autobus de tournée
des fans partout tu gagnes des trophées
tu as ça d'un côté et de l'autre toi ta
vraie vie ton père qui est malade un
enfant élevé des problèmes familiaux à
une éventuelle divorce tu vis tout ça en
parallèle et est-ce que j'ai perdu pied
peut-être
pendant un bout de temps je pense que
j'ai assez de valeur profondes et
ancrées pour savoir que j'ai jamais
complètement dérapé j'ai tout le temps
j'ai toujours gardé ma tête mais à un
moment donné se sentir complètement
dépassé ça oui parce que
en 2001 puis il y en a eu un autre je
projet non diagnostiqué mais tous les
signes physiques étaient là après
Dracula plus tard ou là j'étais allé au
bout de quelque chose dans ma vie que je
referai jamais et j'ai compris quelque
chose parce que ça m'a pris du temps à
revenir donc il y a eu deux moments dans
ma vie où il y a eu des espèces de Burn
Out à cause que tu vis des choses
énormes puis il y a pas de manuel 101
pour pour gérer ça et tu arrives en face
des gens les journalistes les caméras
mais tu montes pas ça
dans ma tête je suis le plus grand à la
fin de votre lit vous abordez un sujet
tabou au Québec l'argent ah ouais ouais
vous dites que vous avez perdu 500 000
dollars au début des années 2000 ça fait
mal ça pour une carrière parce que un
artiste a besoin d'avoir la tête libre
en fait problème financier comment ça
s'est passé pour vous en fait ce qui
s'est passé c'est que j'ai j'avais un
rapport à l'argent comme bien des
artistes j'en avais jamais
j'en avais pas jusqu'à
la fin des années 90 début 2000 où là
mes albums personnels commençaient à me
rapporter et Notre-Dame de Paris est
arrivé dans ma vie et là tout a changé
et je savais pas quoi faire avec ça donc
j'ai fait confiance à des gens et j'ai
perdu de l'argent j'ai perdu beaucoup
aux gens en fait j'ai perdu comme une
retraite l'équivalent peut-être d'une
retraite et donc c'est des gros montants
d'argent qui sont partis parce que vous
l'avez pas dépensé en Ferrari studio ou
un condo dans le sud combien les gens
non j'ai travaillé tellement que j'ai eu
l'idée de dire je vais mettre ça de côté
en attendant puis je verrai plus tard ce
que je fais avec ça
[Musique]
j'ai peur j'ai froid je meurs je vous
parlais aussi de la soixantaine plus
difficile à vivre que la cinquantaine
pour vous mais vous voyez l'avenir avec
Optimus ben un optimisme pondéré dans le
sens que je suis tellement conscient que
le métier d'artiste c'était mon teint
russe alors en ce moment je suis dans un
beau ail je dirais quand je vais sentir
que je suis capable de le donner je vais
pas juste m'accrocher à la nostalgie là
je vais quand je vois sur scène c'est
toujours comme un paraphraser les les
sportifs c'est toujours pour mon sens
50%. donc quand je sentirai je suis
capable de le faire je vais me retirer
ça c'est sûr je vous rassure c'est loin
d'être terminé si on se fie aux ovations
après la reprise de notre âme de Paris
merci beaucoup Bruno Pelletier merci
beaucoup à vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]